yeah i'm disturbed by this [ __ ]
plexiglass whatever the [ __ ] you call it
yeah cause i know you're trying to pra
pro pro practice correct covet protocol
but me being from the hood and you being
asian on the other side of glass
yeah this is where you guys get
empowered
[Laughter]
i'm telling you like in certain
neighborhoods
like the [ __ ] asian person talks more
[ __ ] the thicker the bulletproof glass
yeah
you know what right now you're not gonna
talk to my [ __ ] because i could kick
myself through this
you had that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
here you was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you on
my show
yeah yeah yeah all right that's actually
that's a historical fact
it is a historical fact me and i know
that when you go to a chinese i want to
order something right now all right
all right so when you're in a chinese
restaurant i want you to tell me it's
only going to take five minutes
whatever the [ __ ] door is do you
think that when you're at a chinese
restaurant do you think that we're
talking [ __ ] behind your back behind the
wall
do i think that yeah yeah one
[ __ ] hundred percent oh well then
you're correct i know and the reason why
i know that
because i know the stress on the other i
know the stress on both sides
i know you're trying to provide food for
a community or whatever
and then you get frustrated when someone
comes in here and they say
they want shrimp fried rice and they say
i want extra extra shrimp
right
without respecting how much extra shrimp
costs right
no i need you to throw extra shrimp in
here
and you can't do it would you would you
be angry if they go okay we have to add
five more dollars
uh no i wouldn't be angry with that
because i know if i go somewhere
like right now if i go somewhere i want
extra anything i know it's gonna be
extra cost
right i'm not going there with the idea
if i want extra [ __ ] for the same price
so i can understand where that
frustration comes from right you know
and i don't necessarily think that
that's your commitment
it's so funny about when i say your
community like in um
in uh new york they have a lot of
koreans on like
the markets and stuff right right and a
lot of people
a lot of black people have issues
with their culture and on the other side
the korean culture
has issues with our culture and i think
the thing that
that is more disturbing with korean
culture when it comes to our culture is
the
the lack of respect they have for elders
you know i'm saying like
you know you know you have the old thing
where oh why you following me and
everything like that
and i understand that exists or whatever
but i've noticed especially
being stationed and living in korea i
know how important
um respecting your elders is to your
culture it's very important that that's
some kind of way
you lost that
i specifically you lost that respect for
elders because
i am your elder oh you are you are
you are whatever it
[Applause]
and with that said you know if you ever
spend any time in korea
when you see me you have to show me
respect you know i didn't know we were
not you by those rules
you weren't bad you didn't bother listen
you didn't do that when i came here
you didn't do you didn't do it you
didn't do that i know
you didn't do none of that i'm sorry
you're disrespectful to my culture
and you're also disrespecting you
disrespectful to your coach okay if i
would have known i
i first of all i didn't know that you
ever even spent time
in korea bobby i don't stop the [ __ ]
lies bro or i knew
i knew i knew we've been three [ __ ]
shows
i i i know i smoke more [ __ ]
than you i know i know right no yeah
do you do this to your listeners all the
time what do you lie
yeah do you guys accept it yeah yeah is
it this is a camera for the audience
yeah yeah
you guys accept this level of disrespect
from this [ __ ]
leave your comments listen i'm trying to
improve my game here
as a human being but i do i like you i i
like to look back on my past and my
behaviors and
i also look back at the past podcast and
i want to improve my game
yeah i lie a lot i've exaggerated i
think that in comedy you have to do that
to embellish stories and whatnot
do you embellish stories yeah that's
what part of my like people always ask
me what
when it comes to stand up what is my
style what is my process
and i don't really only